Wir haben ein jahrhundertelang
gehütetes Geheimnis der Elben geknackt.
„Ein kleiner Bissen füllt den Magen einesausgewachsenen Mannes.“
Ja ist doch geil.Ich find’s super!
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier. Im Herrn der Ringe sind die Hobbits Frodo und Sam auf einem dreimonatigen Marsch unterwegs,
von Bruchtal bis ins düstere Mordor. Also eine
Reise, die extrem auslaugt und vor allen Dingen
hungrig macht. Zum Glück haben die Hobbits
und ihre Gefährten aber unterwegs einen ganz
besonderen Proviant bekommen...
„Lembas.“
Das ist ein Reisebrot der Elben, recht
klein und handlich. Aber trotzdem soll
es unglaublich satt machen und extrem
nahrhaft sein. Also da ist alles drin,
was ein Mensch, ein Elb oder ein Hobbit halt
so braucht. Und genau das will ich auch haben,
das backe ich heute nach. Natürlich bin ich da
jetzt nicht der Erste, der auf die Idee kommt.
Also es gibt schon hunderte Varianten von diesem
Rezept im Netz; auch so halboffizielle wie in
diesem „Herr der Ringe“-Kochbuch hier. Wenn man
aber mal genauer reinguckt, dann steht da immer
so etwas drin wie Mehl, Zucker, Backpulver,
Buttermilch… Das klingt mehr nach einem
Kaffeekränzchen als nach einem Superfood für
die lange und gefährliche Reise bis nach Mordor.
Ich brauche also eine völlig neue Rezeptur und
für die will ich Tolkien beim Wort nehmen. Also
ich möchte ein Brot backen, das tatsächlich
unseren kompletten Tagesbedarf an Kalorien,
Eiweißen, Vitaminen und so weiter abdeckt.
Lasst uns gemeinsam diese Rezeptur finden,
hier in einer Bäckerei der Festung Königstein in
der sächsischen Schweiz. Aber das machen wir nicht
allein, ich habe mir Hilfe geholt. Von einer,
die weiß, was ein gutes Brot können muss,
nämlich Ernährungswissenschaftlerin Doris Winter.
Doris kennt sich bestens mit Zutatenlisten und Nährwerttabellen aus. Ihre Leidenschaft für Lebensmittel hat sie seit ihrem Au-pair-Jahr
in Frankreich und Großbritannien. Mit Spargel kann man sie jagen, dafür hat
sie ein absolutes Lieblingsgericht:Kartoffeln, Spinat und Spiegelei.
Doris, herzlich willkommen bei „So schmeckt Herr der Ringe“ würde ich es jetzt nennen.
Herzlichen Dank für die Einladung.
Du hast uns viele schöne Sachen mitgebracht. Trotzdem eine ketzerische Frage am Anfang: Warumbrauchen wir das alles? Also warum nehmen wir
nicht einfach so ganz normale Supermarktbrote mit
auf die Reise? Wenn ich davon jetzt ein halbes
Stück esse, bin ich ja auch erst mal richtig satt.
Also die Energieversorgung wäre auf jeden Fall gewährleistet. Aber wenn wir, wie Sam und Frodo,mehrere Wochen unterwegs sein wollen, dann wollen
wir uns natürlich auch auf die Nährstoffeverlassen. Wir machen das wie die römischen
Legionäre früher. Die hatten einen Getreidebrei dabei, sehr wahrscheinlich aus Vollkorn.
Und das Brot, was wir heutzutage im Supermarktkaufen können, ist eigentlich nur Weißmehl,
also eigentlich nur Zucker. Und das macht auf
Dauer unglücklich und krank. Deswegen machen
wir das heute mit schönen Vollkornprodukten.
Das ist ja auch wirklich eine anstrengende Reise, die Frodo und Sam da vor sich haben. Die müssen Gefahren durchstehen, die müssen
im Ernstfall bereit sein, schnell wegzulaufen.
Die müssen aber auch gleichzeitig Rätsel lösen,
als sie ihren Kopf fit halten. Also die brauchen
definitiv mehr als nur schnelle Kalorien.
Genau, also die Basissachen, die der Körper so
braucht. Kohlenhydrate, Fette, Eiweiß, Vitamine
und Mineralstoffe. Das haben wir alles dabei.
Super! Dann versuchen wir all das mal in
einem einzigen Brot unterzubekommen. Damit wir
jetzt nicht einfach irgendetwas zusammenhauen,
sondern auch noch optisch und geschmacklich an das
Original rankommen, müssen wir natürlich wissen,
wie unser Endprodukt richtig werden soll. Dafür
haben wir eine richtige „Herr der Ringe“-Expertin
befragt, Ester Stroh vom YouTube-Kanal Moviepilot.
Hallo Doris, hallo Jack, hallo liebe Science vs.
Fiction-Fans! Das Brot ist eigentlich gar kein
Brot, sondern eher eine Art Keks. Also sehr
haltbar, aber nicht so hart wie Zwieback. Und
manchmal wird Lembas deswegen auch mit einer
Waffel oder Oblate verglichen. Es ist auf jeden
Fall innen weiß und außen braun und Gimli erklärt
im ersten „Herr der Ringe“-Roman, das es sogar
süßlich schmeckt. Er vergleicht es geschmacklich
mit Honigkuchen. Die wichtigste Eigenschaft für
die 38 Tage Reise von Lothlórien nach Mordor ist
aber, dass es richtig satt macht, weil es nämlich
aus einem fiktiven Super-Getreide der Elben
gebacken wird. Legolas erklärt im ersten Film…
„Ein kleiner Bissen Füllt den Magen
eines ausgewachsenen Mannes.“
Das Problem ist, das Lembas-Rezept ist
ein gut gehütetes Geheimnis. Also eigentlich
wird das Brot auf keinen Fall an Sterbliche
gegeben. Für Frodo und Sam ist das schon eine
riesengroße Ausnahme, denn es wird gemunkelt,
dass Sterbliche, die von dem Brot essen, danach
den Drang verspüren, in den Westen, also in die
Unsterblichen Lande zu gehen. Und das wollen
die Elben natürlich auf jeden Fall verhindern.
Als keine Chance für uns, irgendetwas aus dem
Originalrezept abzugucken. Aber Doris süß,
hochkalorisch, extremer Haft… das
kriegen wir hiermit hin, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Du kannst ja schon mal anfangen
und hier die Leinsamen mit sechs Esslöffeln
Wasser mischen. Die müssen nämlich erst mal
ein bisschen aufquellen, das dauert eine Weile.
Sechs Esslöffel?
Elben sind ja Vegetarier.
Bin ich auch!
Damit das Boot für möglichst viele von Euch auch
machbar ist, haben wir das sogar vegan gestaltet.
Man kann sich auch mit einer veganen Ernährung,
wenn die gut gemacht ist, optimal versorgen.
Das finde ich super, dass wir das machen. Wir
haben trotzdem eine kleine Herausforderung. Wir
müssen ja irgendwie Menschen, Hobbits und Elben
unter einen Hut bringen. Wie machen wir das?
Also Hobbits sind ja eher ein bisschen kleiner,
haben vielleicht so einen Nährwert-Bedarf
eines Jugendlichen. Elben sind dafür ein
ganzes Stück größer, also nehmen wir einfach
mal die gute Mitte. Einen erwachsenen Mann
zwischen 25 und 51. Ich habe jetzt in
einigen Nährwerttabellen nachgeschaut
und eben diesen Bedarf zusammengestellt.
So sind die Zutaten hier zusammengekommen.
Okay, super! Das heißt, mit dem Brot haben wir
dann, im Bestfall, den Tagesbedarf von einem
erwachsenen Mann komplett abgedeckt.
Genau.
Super! Okay, was ich als nächstes?
Also, du kannst schon mal die
Walnüsse ein bisschen zerkleinern…
Uhh ja, pass auf. Dafür habe ich sogar etwas
vorbereitet, nämlich… Isildurs Klinge!
Damit bekommen wir die klein. Was
ist hier gutes drin?
Also da sind wichtige,
ungesättigte Fettsäuren drin. Die haben wir
hier auch in dem Moon und Fette sollte man
überhaupt nicht verteufeln. Die sind ganz wichtig
für den Körper. Zum Beispiel als Energiespeicher,
als Polsterung für die inneren Organe und
auch als Transportmittel für, zum Beispiel,
die fettlöslichen Vitamine E, D, A und K.
Und was passiert, wenn wir da zu
wenig von bekommt?
Bei einem Mangel an
Omega-Fettsäuren kam es zu hässlichen Sachen
wie Haarausfall, Wundheilungsstörungen
oder brüchigem Nägeln kommen.
Dann sehen wir am Ende alle aus wie Gollum,
das wollen wir auf jeden Fall nicht. Dann hack
ich das jetzt und pack das, mit dem Moon zusammen,
in die große Schüssel.
Okay, was haben wir noch?
Wir haben hier Haferflocken, das ist unser
Kohlenhydratlieferant. Die liefern Sam und
Frodo die richtige Energie auf dem Weg.
Wir haben eine Vollkornvariante gewählt,
da sind extra viele Ballaststoffe drin. Die
haben wir zum Beispiel auch im Trockenobst,
dem Buchweizen und in den Bananen.
Ballaststoffe sind unverdauliche,
langkettige Kohlenhydrate. Die machen extra
lange satt und treiben den Blutzucker nicht
so schnell nach oben, sodass man dann auch
nicht so schnell wieder Heißhungerattacken hat.
Das klingt total gut und ich nehme
an, ich mache das jetzt einfach klein.
Du machst das klein und dann
geben wir das gleich mit dazu.
Jetzt brauchen wir auf jeden Fall auch
noch etwas für die Muskeln und Knochen
[Yes!]
Genau, dafür brauchen wir also Calcium
und Proteine. Proteine haben wir hier vor allem in
den Hanfsamen drin. Da muss ich auch direkt mal an
Gandalf denken, der immer sein Pfeifenkraut
raucht. Proteine haben wir auch noch in den
Haselnüssen und in den Leinsamen. Und das Calcium?
Was glaubst du denn, wo der am meisten drin ist?
Also ich hätte jetzt normalerweise Milch gesagt,
aber die ist nicht da. Haselnüsse vielleicht?
Fast: Also in absteigender Reihenfolge, in den
Leinsamen, in den Haselnüssen und auch in den
Sanddornbeeren. Und im Sanddorn ist auch extra
viel Vitamin C drin. Und das, zusammen mit den
Proteinen, unterstützt die ordentliche Funktionen
vom Immunsystem. Das ist natürlich wichtig auf so
einer langen Reise, damit man nicht krank wird.
Das kannst Du jetzt auch alles Mal noch
zerkleinern und mit in die Schüssel geben.
Mach ich!
Okay, also mit dem Proteinen,
Kohlenhydraten und Fetten haben
wir jetzt alle wichtigen Energien für
den Grundumsatz schon mal zusammen.
Ja, und die brauchen die total. Es ist
eine super lange Reise. Und Fun Fact:
ein Forschungsteam von der Uni Leicester
hat das sogar mal durchgerechnet. Also,
wie viele Kalorien Frodo und seine Gefährten
insgesamt verbraucht haben könnten. Die sind
auf rund 1,8 Millionen Kilokalorien
gekommen. Also ganz schön viel. Doris,
wie viel wird am Ende in unserem Boot drin sein?
Ungefähr 2500 Kilokalorien. Das ist der
Nährwertbedarf für einen erwachsenen Mann.
Wir sind fast durch, ein paar Zutaten sind
noch da. Genau. Wir wollen jetzt noch ein
paar Mineralien reinwerfen, also Phosphor,
Kalium und Magnesium zum Beispiel. Und das
haben wir hier alles in der Weizenkleie drin.
Das ist die Randschicht vom Weizenkorn.
Also das ganze gute Zeug, was für Dein
Weißmehlbrot einfach weggeschmissen wird.
Dann haben wir noch ein bisschen jodiertes
Speisesalz und für die Extraportion Jod
packen wir auch noch ein bisschen Alge rein.
Ja, das hab ich mich vorhin schon
gefragt. Algenblatt tatsächlich ins Brot?
Genau. Wir wollen ja ein
bisschen was Besonderes haben.
Dann haben wir hier noch Kakao und das ist
schade, dass Ihr das nicht mitbekommt aber das
riecht echt super gut. Wofür ist der da?
Als fermentiertes Produkt steht der
stellvertretend für B12. Und das ist ganz wichtig
für Blut, Zellteilung und das Nervensystem.
Dann würde ich sagen, hauen
wir alles rein. Endspurt!
So. Wir haben jetzt hier unsere fertige
Lembasbrot-Rohmasse. Da sind natürlich noch
hundert andere Vitamine und Mineralien drin, die
wir jetzt nicht besprochen haben. Fakt ist, damit
sind wir für eine lange Reise gewappnet. Und wir
haben das Ganze noch mal durch einen Mixer gejagt
und noch mal 200 ml Wasser dazu gegeben, damit
dass einfach eine teigigere Konsistenz bekommt.
Dann lass uns das doch jetzt aufs
Backblech packen. Ich fette das schon
mal ein bisschen ein. Und ich habe noch diese
quadratischen Ausstechförmchen hier besorgt,
damit das am Ende auch wirklich so aussieht
wie in den „Herr der Ringe“-Filmen.
Mega cool, Doris. Man muss das
nochmal festhalten. Wir haben
hier ein jahrhundertelang gehütetes Geheimnis
der Elben geknackt, finde ich ziemlich geil.
Ich mache ja immer noch diese typischen Kreuze
rein. Doris, wie müssen wir das jetzt backen?
Also ich würde sagen 200 Grad,
probieren wir mal eine halbe Stunde aus.
Sieht voll gut aus!
Ist super! Also es ist auf jeden
Fall süß, aber nicht so süß. Also Honigbrot ist
es jetzt nicht aber gerade für so eine Wanderung,
oder wenn du lange unterwegs bist…
Ja, kann man auf jeden
Fall machen. Richtig lecker.
Und schau mal hier sind noch Aprikosenstücke
drin. Also ich würde sagen, unbedingt nachmachen.
Und jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur, dass wir es noch
schön einpacken. Beim „Herrn der Ringe“ machen
die das mit Mallornbaumblättern. Die haben wir
jetzt nicht, weil es den Mallornbaum bei uns
nicht gibt. Wir nehmen diese Bananenblätter,
da kann ich das mal schön einwickeln. Ich finde,
die kommen optisch auf jeden Fall schon super ran.
Auf jeden Fall noch ein kleiner Hinweis für Euch,
wenn Ihr das nachmacht. Das ist ein Reisebrot,
also sehr ballaststoffreich. Bitte unbedingt viel
trinken, wenn ihr das esst. Und eins wird auf
jeden Fall auch klar. Wenn wir hier die Menge
sehen, mit einem Bissen ist das nicht getan.
Also wie Legolas lass uns das erzählt hat. Also
wir kriegen aus der Masse insgesamt so acht
bis zehn von diesen Lembasbroten raus. Da hat
Legolas den Mund ein bisschen zu voll genommen
beziehungsweise das genaue Gegenteil.
Was würde passieren, wenn wir einfach
mehr davon essen? Hält das dann auch länger?
Leider nicht. Eigentlich zählt jeder Tag für sich.
Wenn wir das über eine längere Zeit machen, dann
nehmen wir einfach zu. Also haben dann Reserven
für Notzeiten und so haben wir ja bisher auch
ganz gut überlebt. Aber erstens werden wir dann
auch nicht unbedingt fitter und zweitens kann
man die Vitamine auch nicht um unendlich viel
aufnehmen. Also die werden dann teilweise auch
einfach wieder ausgespült. Eine abwechslungsreiche
Ernährung macht ja auch viel mehr Spaß. Da
wird man auch nicht so schnell unglücklich.
Wir wollen Euch ja vor allen Dingen glücklich
machen. Ich hoffe, das haben wir geschafft,
mit diesem ganz neuen Lembasbrotrezept. Mich würde
voll interessieren: Habt Ihr das ausprobiert? Wie
ist es geworden? Schmeckt es Euch und findet Ihr,
dass das „Herr der Ringe“ würdiges Lembasbrot ist?
Lasst mal einen Kommentar dazu da. Und
außerdem würde ich mich sehr freuen, wenn Ihr…
abonniert und die Glocke drückt!
Dann können wir uns nämlich in
14 Tagen schon Wiedersehen. Doris,
vielen vielen Dank. Das war die erste
richtig leckere Folge von Science vs. Fiction.
Danke noch einmal für die Einladung und Euch zu
Hause: Ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Guten Appetit!
[Ich hab auch noch Isildurs
Klinge. Isildurs Klinge? Ist
das richtig? Isildurs Klinge!!!]
[Doris‘ Gesicht! ]
[Machst Du jetzt in Slow-Motion,
wie Jack sich den Finger abhackt?]